yesterday Walmart which is the world's
largest retailer announced that it is
now taking sides in the gun debate the
company announced it will longer sell
handgun ammunition in its doors nor
Walmart says will it stock common rifle
rounds that can be quote also used in
large capacity clips on military-style
weapons and then the company went even
further than that
Walmart CEO Doug McMillon issued a
strident statement calling on Congress
to ban many semi-automatic rifles that
Americans have as well as to seize
firearms from some Americans who have
not been convicted of a crime or even
charged with anything for a company that
operates primarily in rural America all
of this was a big step how do rural
Americans feel about it well we can only
guess at that there's not a lot of
polling going on in to dot Montana or
Roxbury Maine but we do know that in the
most expensive parts of New York City
and Washington and Los Angeles all the
smart people were deeply impressed they
love Walmart now you know good for
Walmart for for doing this and these are
weapons of war maybe what's actually
happening here is Walmart is listening
to its own customers and listening to
the American people who want changes in
not only in the stores but in society
you have business being able to act in a
more enlightened and more agile way than
government does at least Walmart today
announced new action insisting that the
status quo is unacceptable
I was surprised happily surprised I
think this is a momentous decision a
watershed moment
uh-huh so now Walmart is more quote
enlightened than government is says
liberals that's a fascinating turnaround
because for years you'll remember
Walmart was the target of coordinated
attacks from the left progressives used
to attack the company for destroying
small-town America and for exploiting
workers Walmart hired PR consultants and
Union Buster's to push back for years
but the company never really changed the
way it does business and yet somehow the
left is mostly stopped attacking them
hmm how'd that happen well part of the
answer is that liberals got rich and
then lost interest in economics they
adopted identity issues instead but
Walmart meanwhile figured out that it
could buy immunity from criticism from
the left by mouthing left-wing piety
that's all it takes really sounding
and they'll leave you alone notice that
Walmart plans to sell the remainder of
its ar-15 ammunition so this couldn't
really be about saving lives obviously
it's about the money it's only about the
money and that's not a surprise because
there's a lot of money at stake by
revenue Walmart is the largest company
in the world the walton family is the
richest family in america collectively
they're worth more than a hundred and
fifteen billion dollars that they get so
ritual by selling foreign goods to
domestic consumers cheap chinese garbage
manufactured offshore in factories that
pay slave wages wages that american
manufacturers could never match
according to one study from 2001 to 2013
america actually lost 400,000 jobs
thanks to Walmart's reliance on Chinese
imports and it shows here's what many
American towns look like today thanks to
Walmart here are some of the gleaming
new cities that the Communist Chinese
government built with the profits look
at that any wish we had that we don't at
times Walmart sold goods at a loss just
long enough to drive American
competitors out of business completely
small retail and the jobs they provide
it just vanished in many places Walmart
became one of the few remaining
employers as of today more than one and
a half million Americans ending one-time
work at Walmart and it's not by and
large an improvement over what we had
before and it's not getting better in
2005 for example 20% of Walmart
employees worked part-time at the
company today the majority work
part-time why you know why if Walmart
keeps employees hours low enough it can
avoid paying them benefits people can't
really live like that and Walmart knows
it but they know the federal government
that is to say you taxpayers will
subsidize their low wages with welfare
benefits in other words you are working
so that the Walton family won't have to
pay their employees enough to live
that's happening right now but we're not
talking about it because Walmart is now
pushing gun control so take three steps
back and let's think about what's
happening here the company more
responsible than any other company for
destroying and degrading rural America
for making our towns uglier and cheaper
and poorer the same people who push the
appalling lie that brightly colored
plastic
from China is gonna make us happy that
company is now lecturing normal
Americans the very Americans they have
hurt about how immoral they are for
daring to protect themselves with
firearms that's what they're saying and
everyone in Washington New York and Los
Angeles is applauding them as they do it
it's not a good sign